aren't you unfairly blaming Latino
immigrants for unemployment and crime in
this country no no proven to be right on
that point we brought immigration of
illegal immigration up and by bringing
it up it's the number-one topic in the
United States right now and now
everybody's apologizing to me because I
happen to be well a lot of Latino voters
are not apologizing they're very small
in the bottom they're calling you a
racist how do you remarkable how you're
rolling that I gotta just came out where
I'm Way number one in Nevada with 28% of
the vote right also one i also one very
easily the hispanic vote with
30-something percent so that's good so
as a billionaire and as part of the 1%
how could you possibly represent let
alone relate to the remaining 99% of
america i relate to most is the middle
class then how can the middle class in
this country is being decimated i will
bring back a very strong very powerful
one really a wonderful middle class well
thank you everybody thank you middle
class
you